اهلا بكم في موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره
اعلنا الادعاء العام في مدينه نيويورك
هيئه محل كبرى في منهات صوتت لصالح توجيه
تهم الى الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب بشان دفعه اموالا لاسكات ممثله
اباحيه لاجل تغيير مسار تحقيق قضائيه وقال
مراسل الجزيره انه تم الاتفاق بين الادعاء
العام في نيويورك وهيئه الدفاع عن تشرب
لتسليم نفسه للتحقيق الثلاثاء القادم
ودفع دونالد ترامب عن براءته وقال ان
توجيه التهامي اليه اضطهاد سياسي وتدخل في
الانتخابات على اعلى مستوى في التاريخ
هذا وقالت شرطه نيويورك كانها لن تتسامح
مع اي عنف وذلك بالتزامن مع اصدار لائحه
اتهامه للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب مضيفه
انها ستراجع خطط انتشار افرادها لمواكبه
التطورات الامنيه
في السودان قال المتحدث باسم العمليه
السياسيه خالد عمر يوسف للجزيره ان لجنه
صياغه توصيات ورشه الاصلاح العسكري
والامني ستواصل جلساتها اليوم الجمعه واذا
لم تحسم كل القضايا فستتم مناقشه تعديل
الجدول الزمني لاكمال هياكل السلطه
المدنيه
يتوافد الاف الفلسطينيين على حاجز قلنديا
لاداء صلاه الجمعه الثانيه من شهر رمضان
المبارك في المسجد الاقصى هذه هي صور
مباشره من الحاجز وفي القدس المحتله حشدت
شرطه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي نحو الفين من
عناصرها في انحاء المدينه هذا ويعزز جيش
الاحتلال من وجوده على الحواجز العسكريه
بين الضفه والقدس
[موسيقى]
بحث وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه في اتصال مع
نظيره الاسرائيلي
جهود تعزيز المصالح المشتركه واهميه
العلاقات الثنائيه بين واشنطن وتل ابيب
والتحديات المشتركه وقالت الخارجيه
الامريكيه نابلينكن رحب بجهود خفض التوتر
بين الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين واكد على
اهميه الامتناع عن اي اجراءات نحاديه من
جهتها قالت الخارجيه الاسرائيليه ان
الوزيرين بحث الحوار الجاري في اسرائيل
بهدف التوصل الى اتفاق بشان موضوع الاصلاح
القانوني
اعلنت روسيا اعتقال مراسل صحيفه سوست جونا
الايفن جيرش كوفيتش متلبسا بالتجسس وقالت
ان نشاطه لا يمت بصله للعمل الصحفي في
المقابل نفت الصحيفه بشده تهم الموجهه
لمراسلها بالتجسس
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن عن
قلق بلاده البالغ انباء الاعتقال ووصفه
بالقمع والترهيب من جانبه طلب نائب
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكي او
الامريكيين بمغادره روسيا فورا لان بقائهم
لم يعد امنا على حد قوله
كتاب المعجزه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]